i went to lola's cupcakes and the sister
who served me her hair was showing now
to me that was
becoming alarming in the context where i
was like okay if it's once you
understand people have their struggles
and i talk about this people different
people have different struggles
and the fact that you're seeing it more
and more sometimes you know
psychologically you can say that
if you notice something once and it bugs
you you will see that more and more not
necessarily
because there is more of it it's because
now your mind is open to
it i disagree that i don't think i'm
looking for it
but i think it's become a pandemic so as
a muslim man do i have a right to be
concerned and voice my opinion or do i
just have to be quiet because it's a
woman's issue
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before assalamu alaikum what
happened today better care to brothers
and sisters and dear friends hope you
guys are wearing inshallah welcome back
to my channel
as you guys may have known i've seen um
i i discussed the issue of hijab
um and when we talk about hijab i'll
talk about you know both men and women's
hijab and i think there's a big
misconception where
men tend to talk about hijab and i don't
think there's anything wrong with that
but the thing is i would personally say
maybe i'm the first
i'm not trying to get credit or both but
i'm just being real i think i'm the
first maybe
huge youtuber in the dollar scene who
has brought light to men's hijab
you know i've done this with a social
experiment
i've done this where i've done direct
videos about men's hijab
but yet again there are still sisters
who are still upset and be like no
why do you have to talk about hijab and
that's the reason why we have sister
fayema here today
from sister alaikum salaam how are you
yeah good how are you doing very well
thank you thank you for inviting me
today
it's a pleasure may allah bless you
inshallah can you tell us a bit about
what you do and who you are
yes um again uh salaam alaikum to you
and everybody that's watching um
i am fahim mohammed i am a qualified
life coach and a certified nlp
practitioner which stands for
neuro-linguistic programming that's
basically understanding
the human mind behavior and habits and
changing it
also certified in existential positive
psychology
mindfulness relationship and couples
coaching as well as
certified to coach in companies and
institutes
also a certified mental health
and wellness practitioner and continuing
with neuroscience in confidence and
change and
on a ongoing journey of self-development
and learning as we speak so yes
continuous
learning of human mind and behavior
generally
that's amazing it seems like your
religion tells you to cover your hair
not your brain you know it doesn't seem
like you're
you're oppressed so mashallah says fame
as you can see her credentials
and actually sister fema along with
sister lauren and other
uh people as well both men and uh
brothers and sisters are working on a
project with the whole
marriage documentary and the app that
we're working on she she's going to be a
great part of that which should be
helping us
uh we would develop help build a
foundation for those who are seeking
uh to get married to help them in the
marriage seeking process but thus coming
out later this year inshallah we've been
working hard
on it uh anyway so let's get straight to
the topic so um
i'll tell you where this is coming from
and i did speak to you um
as well about this where i was out with
my wife in westfield
and um when i was doing some shopping we
had some few things to do so
i went to jd sports yeah now these
things obviously things that
you don't look for but you see so i saw
a sister there
um she had a hijab on but the front of
her hair was showing and she had like um
i wouldn't say sideburns like maybe
these things that has
her hair basically and then we was
walking in
uh westfield and then i saw a few other
sisters like you know it's apparent
because you know you're looking around
you can see it
sisters with their front of their hair
showing you know and they wear the hijab
at the front their hair showing
i went to lola's cupcakes and the sister
who served me her hair was showing
now to me that was becoming alarming in
the context where i was like
okay if it's once you understand people
have their struggles and i talk about
this people different people have
different struggles you know what i'm
trying to say
and i respect that but when i was seeing
this systematically and i can remember
maybe a week or ten days ago we went to
acton
and we went to all the food and we saw
two sisters who came in
and the same thing and i was like yo
like what is going on and i'm being
honest i'm genuinely as a brother
confused in the context now i don't know
how you feel about this
and i know you're going to be maybe
grilling me or asking me questions which
i admire and i think that's how it
should be
to get rid of these misconceptions but
as a muslim man
do i have a right to feel concerned
that sisters who are like for example
we do see for example hijab and really
tight clothing
so as a muslim man do i have a right to
be concerned and voice my opinion or do
i just have to be quiet because this is
a woman's issue
um very very interesting points you've
raised there actually
and um yes i hear you clearly
um i don't think it's a question about
whether it's a man's position or not
because i think as muslim if we have
genuine concern about islam
then yes there is also the fact that we
want to raise awareness it's just that
nowadays i do feel
that a lot of people um maybe even some
have accused you of being in this way
where when it comes to women the only
thing that people
ever really speak about is the hijab
like as if like you said
you know my brain is not covered but so
you know it's
you know and it's not an oppression
thing so i'm educating myself and also i
forgot to mention i actually am on live
tv every week on different channels from
different sect
and i speak on various current issues
and i do put myself out there
so i want to represent in our community
as well as outside
and wearing hijab myself i have been
obviously
uh you know putting myself out there
because i want to empower other women to
do the same
as well as feel that they can do and be
whatever they want regardless of being
seen in a particular way
however at the same time in our own
community we can be scrutinized a lot
for not wearing it in a particular way
and
the rules are very very clear the
guidelines
are there we all know that but
unfortunately
um depending on a person's journey which
is no excuse
but it is a reason where some women may
find it
quite difficult to actually fulfill the
complete requirements of hijab and i
also have to say that hijab is not just
a head covering by the way
it's so much more than that um you know
when we even have women that are
actually dressing full covering
in the actual way that islam dictates
and and guides us
um we also find that the behavior the
attitude is not there so then where do
we draw the line when it comes to that
we're not speaking about that either
because it has to be a club there has to
be etiquette there has to be
so much more around hijab that we need
to mention and yes
this is always going to come up and i
think it's not just the men that's
criticizing women or looking at it in
that particular way i think it's also
other women
that needs to show a bit of empathy a
bit of understanding so that we are
drawing more
women towards um the right path and
being open to it as well as giving
understanding and the fact that you're
seeing it more and more sometimes you
know psychologically you can say that
if you notice something once and it bugs
you you will see that more and more not
necessarily
because there is more of it it's because
now your mind is open to it
and it's like if you choose one card
that you like you'll always
run into seeing that at once that's true
actually you know like
there was a specific card that i wanted
and i would see everybody commenting
everywhere when you give your attention
to it
but i'm gonna beg to differ here because
i genuinely believe at this very
instance
it's it i believe it's actually becoming
like
i don't think it's that i was looking
for it i think it was that i saw it once
i was like okay
everyone has that one and then i saw it
again and then i saw it again
and then i saw it again so when i saw it
again i i
maybe i disagree that i don't think i'm
looking for it
but i think it's become a pandemic in
the context where
you know we've got the whole virus here
but i'm not trying to equate to that
with my wordings yeah
but the thing is um is that i'm asking
this question like what's going on
because i genuinely are a sister you
understand what's going on because
because
do i have a right to voice this do i
just be quiet because you know the
feminists are going to attack me
what does one do because you know we are
told to enjoy good and fit with evil
and if we remain silent about this then
who's going to tell
who what is and i wish there was
youtubers like
sisters out there who did things the
right way and sadly i believe the
social influences played a massive role
in this whole hair thing showing
am i wrong no um you're right in many
ways but you're also
missing some points again i don't really
think that you're looking for certain
things but subconsciously our mind is
wired in a particular way
when something is obviously you know
seen to us whether you
are looking for it or not so that's one
way of looking at that other
other than that i think hijab is a real
struggle for women which people are not
talking about
it's not about not just wearing it in a
particular way a lot of
women may not be even addressing it
because they themselves feel that
they're not wearing it right
so they don't have the reason to come
forward to speak about their struggles
sometimes
or if they are wearing in a particular
way it's their own thing
and that's how it is also it is a
political statement now
and i look at it as a powerful statement
personally that's why
that we are also being you know attacked
for it that's why
we are even being you know in certain
countries where we are not allowed to
wear it because i look at it as a
powerful statement
but i think we're not giving the
education to women to look at it in that
way
and i think if we are i don't think that
you shouldn't talk about it i think the
way we address it
shouldn't be about just expressing what
is wrong
but trying to be more inviting as to
if you were to do it in a particular way
what are the benefits
for you and how is it protection and
power
for you and not enough people have the
right
look if people wear the hijab doesn't
mean they're religious let's just also
be honest about that
okay just because they're wearing it
doesn't mean that they're religious and
what how do we even define religion even
and just because you actually wearing it
in a particular way which you seem to
deem as okay it's proper covering it's
loose clothing
does that really mean that they're
actually even you know conforming and
performing in everything whole and
you know in their religious kind of
context okay we're not asking for
them to perform everything but it's as
good as me
being in a fob and a beard and i've got
a
a a girl right next to him and i've got
my arm around her well we see that a lot
as well
yeah that's it well that's the issue
because the thing is this issue of the
hijab
it's not just for women it's for men as
well and and
i believe no one has the right to
criticize me specifically
because i've talked about men's hijab
extensively all the time so
and not only that i did an experiment
which has nearly got a million views
which i was subscribed i mean
i was should subscribe as well i was uh
yeah is that i went to muslim so what
happened is two and a half years ago it
was ramadan
it was it was the heat wave yeah it was
crazy
and i thought to myself my gosh man i
wonder what the sisters are going
through
and it was an instant moment where i had
the moment i fought it and to
even act upon it i drove straight to
stratford i
i wrote a message on my phone saying um
my dear sister maya bless you for
wearing this hijab
in this hot weather against all odds
because there were some influences who
took off their hijabs
and i thought right like you know
because people look up to them and i
would go to
i would approach this summer islamic
sister can you read this she'll read it
and i'll walk off
and the point behind that was to
enjoying good and forbid evil evil and
try to encourage them in a positive way
you know calling them to patients like
allah says in surah
you know um by time everyone's in lost
except those who believe and do
righteous deed and call one another to
truth and call one another
to patients so what i was saying is like
you know sister's bare patient etc
so i've done videos like that and there
were some comments where some sisters
said i was about to take my hijab off
it changed my perception i genuinely
tried to feel for our sisters
but i feel as if sometimes i'm being
told to like
no you are not do you think it's that
muslim brothers as a whole
have really done the damage where when
genuine people i hope i'm genuine
that when we come with we're putting the
same category
yeah absolutely i agree with that uh
because like you said your intention is
there to really help
but again when you want to help somebody
um unless you are also
professionally uh trained to go into
somebody's
life and understand them and hear them
first instead of just assuming
that makes a big difference and i've
learned that a lot through my profession
because i can't just go out there and
give advice to somebody i have to make
sure that they want my advice first
and if i'm gonna seek them i get to know
them i build that trust and build that
rapport it's very difficult when you're
doing dawah
as well when you're just gonna give
someone a leaflet and all of a sudden
you see people when i understand human
mind and behavior
a lot of people project and even if
you're coming from a good place you
might catch them at the wrong moment and
they might project something that you
know what
maybe it's triggering the fact that they
know that they're not doing something
you might just get triggered they might
get triggered by what you've said
because they actually believe what
you're doing but in a way they might
attack you for it because like why do
you have to say something like that
so there's many ways and many
perspectives of looking at it so i'm
looking at it from a professional point
of view
and i think that i think we need to
change the way in which we also
try to help and approach people we need
to put things out there
which we like again we need to be
inviting and not intrusive
and not judgmental and not biased and
just because we see someone with a
hijab you know which is half showing
their hair it could just even be
cultural
it could just be where they don't know
any better it could be that they're only
trying it out
you don't know even if you've seen 10
people so what there's how many millions
in this world
right and at the same time when it comes
to men
saying it i think um it's the language
it's terminology it's the timing like i
said do you get to know that person do
you know
you know when i coach clients
professionally there's a process and i
think we need to learn more about the
process of approaching people
just because you have a right there's
still no compulsion in islam as we know
in surah baqarah
okay and we know that we have to give
them a journey the reason why also i
feel that
even though it's a protection even
though it is something that is safe and
for our security
women are still being attacked even in
their own homes women are still being
abused even and this majority of them
are women
so we're not addressing these issues
which is more important
and you know they are looking at hijab
is that oh yes it should be a protection
but sometimes
we're not being protected we're only
being criticized for not wearing it in a
particular way
or not you know being in a particular
way so we need to address more deeper
more social issues which i try to raise
and by the way i am someone who actually
raised a whole topic on sky tv in one of
the platforms
talking about hijab for men as well but
i just don't have the same following as
you
but the thing is i can put on my channel
you know
you know i think it's you know because
hijab is first and foremost for mental
over their gazes by the way yeah so
that's how it's actually translated in
the quran
and again a lot of people don't
understand it it's a lot to do with
etiquette it's a lot to do with manners
it's a lot to do with treatment and
behavior
and we re you know we don't really
recognize that and
again it's and for me i like to
represent outside our community
you know women are looked upon as they
are oppressed and suppressed
only because sometimes we are avoiding
the real issues that are happening to
our women
who are even trying to wear who are
struggling hijab is kind of a jihad you
know it is actually a struggle
and you know we are all taking on that
struggle differently and i think if we
have more empathy towards our women
who are wearing and trying to wear it
then maybe
they might be more open to understanding
where we're coming from
if we have the right language and
terminology okay look the thing is i
understand where you're coming from
like for example that there's a bigger
issue that's happening in the home
or in the house or wherever it may be
and the fact is that allah didn't tell
the woman to cover up because men can't
control their self by the way there's a
big misconception where
people think that allah told a woman oh
you woman you cover up because
men are animals that's not the case
because allah tells us to lower the gate
so they believe in man
and the believing woman to lower the
gaze says the men to lower their gaze
because we're visual creatures you know
and the and the woman covers up so we're
not saying that a woman who wears a
hijab is not prone to get raped
you get it um this is allah we we wear
the
i grow the beard or i have to cover from
my navel to my knee and you need to wear
the hijab and
by whatever it may be because allah
tells me to uh not because
and there's this whole misunderstanding
of oh i choose to no you don't choose to
i don't choose to i'll be honest i don't
choose to say
no no i choose to cover my navel to
money no i do it because allah told me
to do it
it's not a matter of choose to and this
issue this um
statement of i choose to is wrong uh
because at the end of the day
we don't believe that this is this
famous philosopher of course his name
uh i'm bad with names but he said man is
born free but
in shackles everywhere so we believe
that those women who even walk and
maybe wearing mini skirts etc by the way
i i highly believe
that seeing a woman and even no matter
how she's dressed that you should have
the utmost respect
and when i do my social experiments when
i speak to these kind of girls who are
dressed in this
in an appropriate manner i always refer
to them as sister even i always say
what's your name sister alexa sister
sarah i i i do that on purpose so they
feel
that i'm i'm not like you know sadly we
live in a society hypersexualized oh is
he stopping me because
no it's a social experiment yes yeah
sister i want to
i i do that on purpose you know and the
thing is
it's that we need to understand because
what happens is otherwise
is that like you said okay people having
their struggles there's one thing that
people are having their struggles
and there's another thing where for
example if we saw a lot of brothers in
beards and phobes
smoking cigars arguments say now we're
gonna say okay
people are going for struggles there are
people who are smoking they're trying to
quit but when we see a lot of brothers
in phobes and beards
smoking cigars we're gonna start
thinking well hold on a second now
do we start be like oh he's going for a
struggle and he's going to use that as
an excuse
to carry on carry on his struggle
smoking cigar or
do we address the issue so i'm asking
the question and there might be people
listening
sister fahima the question i'm asking is
this i'll be honest with you
i don't understand i understand people
have struggles i understand i had my
struggles
it took me a couple of years to leave
certain sins yeah so it takes time i
understand that
but the moment we're quiet about this
now and i'm not saying it's a massive
crime being committed but what i'm
saying is i'm trying to fathom and
understand
why a sister would cover her hair get
the hijab which is
a yes i understand sometimes it can be
cultural yeah but maybe
maybe i'm wrong maybe most times it's
not to wear the hijab to wake up and say
okay i'm going to put the hijab on
but i'm going to show the front of my
hair now
if it's being worn for the sake of allah
like imagine if
i'm told i have to cover for my navel to
my knee but i show
um like i show my
thighs let's see now and i'm a muslim
i'm clear muslim
yeah i'm wearing the phone but my phobe
is up to a certain point where you can
see my fights it would leave
would we do not leave you a bit confused
in the context like i'm seeing a lot of
brothers and they're showing their
fights
and they are muslims it's clear they're
muslims they're trying to practice
wouldn't you be like what's going on
here
well i think you know what in answer to
your question really it's very simple
for me and i understand where you're
coming from
is the fact that i think a lot of us are
not just are not god centric we're not
that
um believers where we are living
for uh solely for the actual
um practice and religious purposes and
i'm gonna be honest with you
i really believe that because uh
personally i come from different sect
backgrounds different
uh culture in my own family and not
everybody wears the hijab
not everyone is from a first you know
particular sect and
you know we have our own debates and at
the same time for me to take on what i
took on myself
i had to go through a personal journey i
had to go through an actual
learning um and i had to struggle myself
to find
those questions and the answers which
i'm still
in that journey by the way you know
those existential
questions to why am i here what's the
meaning of life yes i learned about
islam my family taught me about it
but i wanted to know why and i wanted to
know more and that takes a particular
type of
individual that wants to do things
namely and forsakely for allah subhana
ta'ala and i think
unfortunately we are in a society where
that is less and less even if we have
the knowledge
we don't have the willpower and the iman
that is strong enough to overcome
you know today's western world and
influences
that's going to keep us on that path
continuously and we are also
infallible and we will have our
weaknesses and shortcomings
at times but if you are on that path you
will continuously strive
and i find that especially dealing with
people with mental health a lot
when they don't have the confidence they
don't have the willpower they don't have
the self-esteem on general issues
faith is sometimes the one thing that is
blamed or the fact that they don't
understand it well enough to realize
that that is their power to a certain
extent to continue to strive
even through the struggles because we
are bombarded like you said with
influences we are bombarded to look
be and see in a particular way i'm quite
strong-minded i always have been
and i have been blessed but there's not
very many people out there
that can say i don't care what you think
i'm just gonna do what i need to do
not because yes it is a choice it's a
choice for me to follow
my creator it's a choice for me to be in
that struggle
it's a choice for me to do what is meant
to be
in the hereafter not just in this dunya
you don't hear these kinds of
conversations
you don't hear about people making
choices because they have the fear
of what's going to happen later on not
fear as in oh because you know we're
going to be punished
but more so as in you know we want to
live
a great life here and the year and the
hereafter
so yes there is a struggle with our
religion there's a struggle with
understanding it
there's a struggle with many
interpretations there's in struggle
with lots of us also just only for you
know concentrating on one or two rulings
but actually the heart and the mind is
very very empty half empty compared to
it being full
and i think that's where the problem is
i think that's very interesting you
touched on something very fundamental
and i think this is where i believe
every single problem on this earth goes
back to it's
tahit it's you know
it's and i think this is very
interesting because i was listening to
one scholar and he said
the main problem is people don't know
who allah is and when we talk about
we don't know allah is because if you
genuinely knew how allah was
there is no way that you fathom who
allah is
but not one but stop yourself from
praying it's impossible
it's like you go to an eight like if you
went to an atheist and said you love god
and he says no i don't i don't even
believe him i'll be like okay do you
love your eye
of course i love my eye how could you
love the design but not the designer
it's impossible how could you love your
nails how could you love yourself and
the way you created
but not love the one who created you you
do but you just don't know him
you don't know him you ascribe the [ __ ]
you ascribe it to mother nature
evolution
random things just made you become like
that and i think what you said is very
important and it goes back to the crux
of the matter because we can be talking
about the leaves
uh but let's go to the branches let's go
to the root of the problem
which is not knowing allah if you
genuinely brother and sisters
understood and this goes for both male
and females if you genuinely understood
who allah is if you took time to spend
and learn
who allah is you will genuinely and this
goes for the sister who might be showing
the hair
because he might be coming through
influences which we'll touch upon and
maybe end on that
it's the thing is that you would say you
know what my love towards allah you will
understand
and cover them for the brothers you
wearing these tight jeans and you know
it makes me sick sometimes i'll be
honest with you you know with the
brothers i can be a bit more harsh
i'll be honest with you when i see it
personally i'm not having i don't want
you to you know
um i'm not getting hate against any
specific community but what i'm saying
is
when i see brothers wearing tight jeans
it makes me sick i'll be honest it makes
me sick
because it's it's it just makes me sick
i'm sorry i'll repeat that again it just
i just i don't get it and i'm like wow
and the thing is it's
you know you have a right to cover as
well and these very brothers when they
come and when they go
like i always mention this when they go
swimming abroad they're topless
and i'm like you're the same guy talking
about sisters pink hijab and you're
and you're talking about says pinkie jab
and you're going toples and all kind of
madness
but the thing is i think what's really
important is we do not give the time to
study our deen
and if we don't do that like they say
every vessel swears what's inside it
if you're too busy consuming you know
materialism
what do you expect it's what you eat
they say you know you are what you eat
you know what you consume then what you
expect something else to be produced
that's what's going to be the the
effects of that the the food
the fruits that you're going to bear is
going to be what you've consumed so if
you're consuming all materialism and
this dunya and
nobody's saying i understand this
insecurity and you know
with sisters etc but i think you've
touched on a brilliant point and i think
this is the crux of the matter
where be the sister showing her hair be
it the one
he answers my question i'll be honest
with you even though i'm in the darwin
you've actually answered my question
because if you think about it deeply
that's what it goes down to well that's
where the root of the problem is
so if i next time see a sister who may
be wearing hijab and showing her hair
i have to remind myself because what you
just said there is something people
think brother ali you're in the tower
you should know that no because allah
says indeed remind the benefits of
believer and what you just said that
clicked with me and i was like
oh then a second actually that's true
you know maybe if i thought about this
before i would have done this video
maybe it's the reason
we've done this video that people can
benefit what you've mentioned as well
and that's very important so brother
sisters knowing a lot is very important
because then you see
that we do things the wrong way around
you know we tell people
that's haram that's haram yes if you
educated people to the dean
they would know it's haram and they
would leave the haram you don't need to
tell them
you know that's why aisha they're
exactly that the prophet saw
his wife he said if if the quran was to
come down
uh with halal and haram nobody would
have come to islam you know it came
with gradual helping you you know jannah
who allah is of course hellfire as well
ending on a note i blame i understand
people have their struggles
and i understand people are not forced
to watch these influences but i believe
the hijabi youtuber influences had a
massive impact on this am i right or
wrong
to a certain extent you're right but
again it goes back down to the
individual are they
kind of people that are easily
influenced as well like i said
um i could easily be influenced if i'm
of a certain mindset
i i'm here to help people be individual
so that they learn about their values
their beliefs so that they can actually
follow it
and that's what i'm trying to do and
even when you said um you know the main
thing is
not just knowing your creator but loving
your creator and the only way you can do
that is to create the connection
and the only way you can create a
connection is for daily practice just
like how we practice watching the
football
when it's time now you know the euro cup
and we want to do everything else with
regards to influences
and you know making sure that we keep up
with the latest fashionistas and what's
going on
we don't actually practice our deen
daily unless it's ramadan or any
particular you know month of the
the year and i personally i'm not just
saying this and i've said this before
not to impress anyone the only way i can
personally keep up with my practice
and have that awareness constantly is i
keep up with my salah
constantly and i have to do it as much
as i can not just leaving out vigil it's
like saying to somebody even
you know you you know you pray five
times and maybe you shouldn't pray pd
about vegeta but no you got to do as
much as you can
and i don't leave the quran i have to
open up that book at least once a day
and read a page
and these are the things that we are not
creating as habits
i'm so sorry have you downloaded the
quran the app
i have got it but i actually read it uh
you know visually i actually like to do
look at it and the book because i have
got the time
i prefer that it's yeah it's absolutely
perfect and i'll do that when i can't
actually visually hold it and read it
but i can actually do that and like i
said there's many options nowadays
if you create certain habits in your
life you will your path will open up for
you
so like you said you know when you are
wanting to do good it's very easy for
you to see it and
be open to it even if someone reminds
you like how we might remind each other
but at the same time if it's a stranger
then you will also look at them
differently and you will also
you know approach them differently and i
think that we do need to
learn about religion differently i think
like you said it's not just about
learning the rights
and the rules and the jurisprudence and
the fact
it's more about understanding what is
the meaning
and the benefits and actually i always
look at my religion as being
protective and powerful do we even say
that anymore no we don't we look at it
as
a fear as in you're going to be punished
if you do this or you don't that now and
that's not how i look at it
so you know interpretation in my way is
you finding yourself knowing yourself
and knowing through that
is firstly your creator and build that
love and connection
you can't go wrong and you can't do
wrong and nobody needs to actually
you know even if they call you out you
look at it as someone there just to help
you and to remind you
and simple so it works for both sides to
be honest okay so
asking my question again does these
influences play a role it does play a
role it most definitely plays a role
because a lot of us are looking at
things
which we think is successful again we're
looking at things which you know uh
people we look at these snapshots and
think that we want that because they are
showing
certain things in life which is
attractive um a lifestyle you know
uh this kind of like you know fantasy
kind of way of living that where they
are successful but i'm telling you now
because i coach some of these you know
so-called influences that even on their
page however
successful they look they are struggling
behind closed doors and even their
assets are not their own
so don't be fooled and live your own
life and
know your own self very well and where
you come from what's your meaning and
purpose
and what you see on social media i'm
telling you now um
it is definitely not real it's not real
and don't fall for it
exactly i i think that will wrap up i
think that was that was great uh brother
and sisters hope you enjoyed this
with sister fahima um and yeah that was
my take on it um you know
and you heard this what's this for him i
said as well i think we i've learned
something new today
i hope you guys have learned something
new today and i think it's important for
us to remind one another as well and i
hope this video has done that
i'm trying to get you know like sister
fahima or sisneya robertson
um and others involved as well because
it's important to have a sister's take
on the mata
because sometimes as a as a male i do i
don't know you know so that's why i'm
trying to
get more sisters involved and yeah if
you guys want more videos on different
topics comment in the section below
insha'allah and we will cover those with
assistant
maybe other sisters as well inshallah uh
until next time uh thank you
much bless you inshaallah for your time
and yeah
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh